hence the reason why
the initiation of divorces is so high
amongst women okay i will say though i
think guys go after bad chicks too i
think it's like
i'll clarify this we may have sex with
bad chicks but we're not watching no not
not i
so what i mean is like toxic like guys
will act like they're above like going
for the toxic girl but oh come on i've
seen so many guys go after pretty toxic
women yeah and i don't i don't believe
for a second because they'll spend years
dating these girls chasing after these
girls do you know why they're chasing
after them as well because they want to
get in the knickers yes
no no but i'm talking no no no
if you're going to spend years that's
what i'm saying condoning it
i'm just saying that no one can speak
for yourself
no but nobody
i i swear to god there is a type of guy
that i run into they like girls that are
a little bit mean to them and i i you
guys degradation sims they're what we
call them they're not they're not but
it's different
no okay okay okay i'll give you an
example i'll give you an example
will smith had the option to pick a girl
he had the option to pick a girl that
was not mean to him you cannot say on
the fresh prince of bel air he did not
have the choice of a woman that did not
that did not treat him like that and i'm
saying as a woman i see this often there
is a certain type of guy a lot of times
they're from like a broken home that's
what i've noticed and i surveyed men on
this too over a thousand men voted in my
poll and they the majority said yes
there's a certain type of guy that likes
girls that are mean to him your your
point of them being from a broken home
yeah is a huge point yeah it's a huge
point because a lot of men that come
from broken homes who are mostly raised
by women
specifically in the black community who
are raised by women right who are have
mothers who are just
overbearing overbearing and you know
aggressive et cetera et cetera some
husbands well but right right yes they
will go for those types of women but
it's not even just like well but and
it's a large percentage of me it's like
more men than i think the manosphere
gives credit for because how many like
i'd say like half of our generation grew
up in a broken home like 50 percent both
men and women yeah and so i think like a
lot of people don't have that like model
to choose from but i think men are
somewhat attracted to a girl that's a
little bit of a [ __ ] do you know what
yeah you might have touched on something
there pearl right because we speak about
women having daddy issues right but we
never speak of men having mommy issues
that's a good point i mean
mommy issues that you don't like there's
a lot of guys out here mommy issues
just an
update on some wild [ __ ] apparently asap
cheated on rihanna